c'est le grand déracinement soixante
mille arbres arrachés dans ce verger des
centaines de milliers d'autres à travers
la californie à mendier comme ceux-ci
série de terre
puis systématiquement déchiquetés
réduits en copeaux
c'est que la californie manque d'eau
alors il faut s'adapter
ce qui tient guère est pour l'heure très
occupé nous essayons d'être aussi
performants que possible avec les
ressources disponibles surtout avec lou
la ressource la plus importante
il n'ya pas d'agriculture sans eau alors
que pouvons-nous cultivé qui résiste
mieux à la sécheresse que les amendes
dépistage peut-être ou autre chose mais
la demande et la culture phare de la
californie 80% des amendes consommé dans
le monde sont produites ici
oui mais voilà leur production demande
beaucoup d'eau 4 litres par noah en
moyenne alors la sécheresse et la
hantise des producteurs nous comptons
sur l'eau et sur l'agriculture pour
subvenir à nos besoins et c'est
terrifiant ce terrain la crise actuelle
est grave
95% de la californie est dans un état de
sécheresse sévère extrême ou
exceptionnels ce qui a poussé le
gouverneur a déclaré l'état d'urgence
le bureau de gestion de l'eau tire la
sonnette d'alarmé chasse est plus
intense que pendant toutes autres années
passées nous à fils et que les
changements climatiques s'accélèrent les
sécheresses s'intensifiant il arrive
plus tôt et plus rapidement que les
problèmes d'eau en californie ne sont
pas nouveaux c'est d'ailleurs pour y
remédier que l'état s'est dotée dans les
années 60 d'un impressionnant réseau de
barrages et de canaux pour récupérer
l'eau issue de la fonte des neiges dans
les montagnes du nord l'entreposer dans
d'immenses réservoirs et l'a transporté
vers les grandes villes du sud
mais cette année l'eau n'est tout
simplement pas au rendez vous la fonte
des neiges dans les montagnes ne réussit
plus à remplir nos réservoirs s'infiltre
vite dans le sol a séché et s'évapore à
cause des températures plus élevées
à la fin du printemps les grands
réservoirs que sont le lac d'euros ville
et le lac folsom devrait être plein ils
ne sont aujourd'hui qu'un peu plus du
tiers de leur capacité
résultat à auroville les bateaux sont
confinés dans une infime portion du
réservoir au lac folsom la situation est
encore pire
on dit souvent qu'une image vaut mille
mots
alors pour donner une idée de l'ampleur
de la crise actuelle il faut imaginer
l'endroit où je me trouve
il y a deux ans jour pour jour il était
recouvert d'eau de beaucoup d'eau 20
mètres au dessus de ma tête
soit l'équivalent d'un immeuble de sept
étages le bassin de browse robin est à
sec
la marina est fermé la saison de
navigation a été annulée 675
embarcations vont donc devoir passer la
belle saison
à terre les cuisines n'a jamais rien vu
de tel
je suis ici depuis presque 25 ans et
c'est le pire que j'ai connue
habituellement les bateaux sont en cale
sèche en novembre ou en décembre
c'est du jamais vu en plein été c'est
triste c'est irréel
la sécheresse extrême et l'intense
vagues de chaleurs actuelles ne sont pas
sans risques les arbres calcinés qui
bordent le lac d'euros villes en sont un
dur rappel à la fin de l'été dernier un
feu de forêt à raser un village entier
ici effet pas moins de seize morts
un brasier que john holmes n'est pas
près d'oublier
si par miracle
sa maison a résisté mais et c'est que la
chance ne sera peut-être pas toujours de
son côté alors l essai tandis que mal de
se protéger son écriture cependant ne
fait qu'augmenter en voyant que le nom
du lac au pied de la montagne ne cesse
de baisser
les californiens sont appelés à réduire
d'au moins 10 % leur consommation d'eau
à mettre un terme au gaspillage
l'arrosage des pelouses par exemple est
déconseillée le jour dit on et la
nouvelle couleur à la mode et les
parterres de pierre sont présentés comme
les plus branchés mais très gourmandes
en eau c'est surtout l'agriculture qui
est montré du doigt des milliers de
fermiers se sont vus retirer leurs
droits d'utilisation de l'eau des canaux
situation qui irrite profondément garde
par lui qui comme beaucoup
d'agriculteurs dans la région a déjà
réduit sa consommation grâce un système
d'irrigation goutte-à-goutte beaucoup
plus économes nous avons déjà adopté
plusieurs solutions
nos systèmes d'irrigation sont plus
efficaces nous surveillons l'irrigation
et notre consommation
selon lui il faut savoir tirer les
enseignements de la sécheresse actuelle
et agir dès maintenant pour trouver des
solutions à long terme
nous sommes dans une crise si nous ne
faisons rien pour régler le problème
nous devons être progresser fait faire
face aux problèmes qui se pointe
sinon comme fermier comme california et
nous affrontons une crise une conviction
que partage doit qui n'esquive elle la
crise selon lui est certes une épreuve
mais aussi l'occasion d'une profonde
remise en question et d'un
investissement majeur pour mieux gérer
l'eau mieux l'entreposer mieux la
recycler nos infrastructures n'ont pas
été construites pour ce climat ni pour
notre époque
nous devons investir rapidement dans des
systèmes pour les décennies à venir dans
ce siècle et dans le prochain nous
devons faire face à la crise des
changements climatiques
pour lui comme pour de plus en plus de
californiens une conclusion s'impose
la sécheresse actuelle ne doit pas être
vu comme exceptionnel mais plutôt comme
la conséquence directe des changements
climatiques une nouvelle réalité à
laquelle la californie comme le reste du
monde n'aura pas le choix de s'adapter
[Musique]